okay well the bakers and the decorators
here at freeze are the professionals but
i'm going
backstage behind the scenes in the
kitchen i'm joined by max we are going
to try our hand at our own gingerbread
houses and this is really fun because
you guys sell these kits for people to
take yeah yeah we actually have
gingerbread house kits that you can
order they ship um they arrive kind of
just well like this they come in a box
uh but all the pieces you see right here
come uh and they work great
a lot of fun um i was gonna mention i
like what you got going on i started all
right yeah it's almost like a cargo
container only because this is actually
the roof
but no but i love what you're doing it
looks you know what we can make our own
rules right right there
you can really do whatever you want here
i was so proud of myself
amazing and if you put a little bit of
icing on like the floor yeah oh
that's how you kind of like actually
stick oh my gosh tips from the
professional max i should have waited
and then if you can kind of go on the
inseam like this okay oh my gosh you
said you weren't very good at that no i
thought i wasn't i have like four
different size walls i think it just
helps being next to somebody who hasn't
done it before that's true and if you
know someone wants to actually buy one
of these houses made by the
professionals they can do that as well
but that's right yeah i mean next to it
you can see like our medium and our
large houses here um although i really
like the creativity you got going on
thank you you know it wasn't on purpose
but i'm just gonna lather as much
frosting as i can because in my opinion
that will make it stick more and i think
it's so fun there's all these different
props inside here you can get santa
sprinkles which are my favorite and even
though we only have a few minutes here i
don't think we can build a whole house
i'm going to try and like speed run this
house right now let's see if we can do
it you know what let's focus on him i'm
giving up my walls don't even match what
this stuff is and just real quick as
you're finishing up the house just talk
about this new location and yeah how
exciting it is to be yeah right now
we're in the back uh the back room of
our downtown location which is uh here
in the arts district and we're just so
excited to be down here um it's our
newest dessert shop uh we stay open a
little bit later at this location
especially on first fridays um so yeah
so on first fridays uh we're here from
11 a.m to 9 p.m
and uh oh no excuse me no we're uh 11
a.m to 11 p.m oh wow yeah we're like
yeah we're like bar time all night
i'm going to eat the m m's that come
there you go okay that's all i can
contribute to this and just real quick
if people want to come by through the
holidays you do have some cookie
assortments and other things available
for purchase yes we have cookie trays
cookie boxes there's all kinds of lovely
treats for people and it's all available
to pick up you can come by any time
although ordering online is definitely
the best way to go about it you go to
freezebakery.com and you can select any
one of our locations uh to pick up from
or even local delivery yeah you guys
make it so easy i ordered my wedding
cake through freed so i can attest it's
delicious it's beautiful oh my gosh the
house
i thought that was yours i was like i'm
not gonna look at it but it was actually
mine
max thank you so much congratulations on
the news location i love that it's a
family-owned business and you guys have
just continued your traditions and
legacy and uh las vegas is lucky to have
you thanks so much we just appreciate
all time thank you max i'm just being
the m ms and we'll leave this